tourismus ist ein gutes thema
wahrscheinlich können sie auch nicht den
den sommerurlaub für uns retten weil wir
wissen halt unsere zuschauer fragen mich
fragen kollegen wo soll ich ihn
überhaupt noch hin reisen können sie die
hoffnungen machen oder ist das alles
wirklich wäre das gelben blick in die
glaskugel
das ist ein blick in die glaskugel das
ja gar nicht von deutschland abhängig
ist im moment sind alle ferienflüge
flieger am boden die allermeisten warum
weil es in den meisten ländern dieser
welt gar keine landeerlaubnis gibt weil
sie ihre grenzen geschlossen haben um
ansteckungsgefahren zu minimieren und
das bedeutet dass man niemanden eine
sicherheit vorgaukeln kann diesem
augenblick nicht gibt wir wissen nicht
wann und wie die usa mit corona mit der
herausforderung fertig werden
wir wissen nicht schließen sich in
anderen ländern entwickeln wird und
deshalb kann ich nur dringend empfehlen
dass jeder bürger sich genau informiert
dass jeder bürger auch weiß dass ihm
niemand im augenblick garantieren kann
dass eine gebuchte reise auch
tatsächlich stattfindet und ich glaube
dass die beratung im reisebüro um die
ecke immer noch in der in der situation
die beste möglichkeit ist weil die
allermeisten reiseveranstalter die sind
ehrliche sind offen zu ihren kunden und
sagen auch dass niemand weiß wann länder
wie beispielsweise die türkei oder
italien oder andere imstande sind den
tourismus wieder hochzufahren immer
wieder auch die frage ich habe jetzt
meinen sommerurlaub gebucht oder ich
habe eine reise im mai oder im april
gebucht ist abgesagt worden
der reiseveranstalter sagt ja da kommt
ja demnächst das gutschein gesetz woran
ich zur zeit noch nicht so glaube die
leute haben angst um ihr geld und sagen
ich brauche die kohle halt ich bin in
kurzarbeit
mir fehlen diese 3000 euro die ich jetzt
bezahlt habe
können sie diesen menschen hoffnung
machen oder oder sollten die tatsächlich
die gutscheine der reiseanbieter
akzeptieren ja wir haben ja wir haben ja
ganz unterschiedliche probleme und
erwartungshaltungen
es ist für viele reiseanbieter wäre es
sehr sehr wichtig wenn sie zunächst
einmal
gutschein ausstellen können ich bin
überzeugt dass viele auch bereits einen
schnaps drauf zu legen damit der
gutschein attraktiv dritten teil auch
schon gibt es zum teil auch schon und
das ist die eine situation zum anderen
gibt es menschen die die wirklich sehr
dringend auf ihr geld angewiesen sind
die in einer schwierigen situation sind
wir beide ehepartner in kurzarbeit sind
beispielsweise und für solche fälle wird
es egal wann der bundestag und ob und
wann er eine gesetzliche regelung
beschließt wird es eine
härtefallregelung geben
das heißt wir haben die im blick die in
einer besonderen situation sind und im
übrigen ist es so dass wir im augenblick
mit der europäischen kommission die
dafür die zuständigkeit hat darüber
sprechen ob und wie man die
entsprechende richtlinie in brüssel
anpassen und verändern kann und ich kann
auch allen versichern wenn sie einen
guten akzeptieren
dann werden wir natürlich dafür sorgen
dass für den fall dass dem unternehmer
dann doch wirtschaftlich irgend etwas
unerwartetes geschieht dass diese
gutscheine nicht einfach verloren sind
aber sie haben es gesagt er brüssel
entscheidet zurzeit ist es so dass
einzelne reiseanbieter schon ihre kunden
informieren über ein gesetz was es im
prinzip noch gar nicht gibt ursula von
der leyen hat weil in der bild am
sonntag gesagt sie sieht das im moment
noch ein bisschen skeptisch wissen sie
da mehr ist brüssel ein bisschen mehr
auf deutscher linie oder wird wird diese
diese guten regelung europaweit dann
letztlich doch blockiert wir haben in
fast allen eu staaten ganz ähnliche
probleme zum einen die vielen menschen
die gebucht haben von denen einige das
geld brauchen und andere gerne bereit
wären den reiseveranstaltern zu helfen
diese schwierige zeit zu überbrücken und
es wäre gut wenn wir in europa eine
einheitliche regelung hätten und keinen
flickenteppich von unterschiedlichen
staaten mit unterschiedlichen maßnahmen
darüber wird im augenblick gesprochen
die kommission die einen vorschlag
vorlegen muss hat das bislang nicht
getan
das können wir auch nicht bei ordnete
mufti anordnen
aber die justizministerin die dafür
zuständig ist gemeinsam mit dem
wirtschaftsminister diese fragen zu
klären wir ziehen an einem strang
und wir möchten dass in einigen tagen
klarheit besteht
wir haben gelesen dass viele auch große
unternehmen staatshilfen bekommen also
aus dem touristikbereich mit sicherheit
eine wirklich eine gute entscheidung
sind denn da alle gleichermaßen dadurch
gesichert oder glauben sie auch dass da
auch unternehmen wird rost fallen ja wir
haben sehr schnell gehandelt schneller
als die meisten anderen länder
weil wir die arbeitsplätze erhalten
wollen es gibt in deutschland rund 45
millionen beschäftigungsverhältnisse
wir möchten dass die so weit es geht
erhalten bleibt deshalb müssen wir auch
den unternehmen helfen zu überleben und
wir haben wir haben vom kleinen
selbständigen der ganz alleine ist dem
wir helfen seine betriebskosten zu
bezahlen indem er dann seine mieter
begleichen kann indem er seine leasing
kosten begleichen kann
über den kleinen mittelständler mit zehn
1500 beschäftigten bis hin zu großen
unternehmen vorsorge getroffen wenn es
irgendwo regelungslücken gibt wenn es
irgendwo dinge gibt die olaf scholz oder
ich übersehen haben
dann bitte ich auch herzlich darum dass
man sich an uns wendet wir werden das
überprüfen wir werden das dort wo es
gerechtfertigt ist auch nachbessern
das haben wir mehrfach getan wir haben
von direkten zuschüssen für ganz kleine
über kreditlinien und garantien und
bürgschaften für die mittleren und für
die großen ein sehr umfassendes angebot
und wir werden gerne dazu beitragen dass
geholfen wird bisher haben über einer
rund anderthalb millionen ganz kleine
selbständige bereits zuschüsse bekommen
bisher haben wir 95 prozent der
kreditanträge an die kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau genehmigt und beschlossen
es gibt geht es in hilfen in
milliarden-höhe bereits zugesprochen
worden
und wir werden auch noch in den nächsten
wochen helfen müssen
denn wir wollen dass die marktwirtschaft
wieder funktioniert wenn die
beschränkungen aufgehoben werden und
marktwirtschaft funktioniert nur dann
wenn es neben verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher auch leistungsfähige
unternehmen gibt ganz kleine genauso wie
mittlere und große also ich habe
den appell auch von den kleineren
reiseveranstalter
spezialreiseveranstalter vielleicht auch
mal ein bisschen luxus oder exotische
sachen die sagen halt wie sind so ein
bisschen vergessen worden die großen
kriegen das geld aber die gehen davon
aus dass gerade kleine unternehmen
tatsächlich wirklich auch die grätsche
machen weil sie halt natürlich nicht das
kapital haben haben sie die auch auf der
uhr sie haben ja eben angedeutet dass
das es da vielleicht auch möglicherweise
nachbesserungsbedarf gibt oder oder
glauben sie dass natürlich den großen
erstmal am besten geholfen ist weil da
geht es um arbeitsplätze und natürlich
auch ein größere volumina sind die
kleinen so ein bisschen ja haben die
dadurch probleme werden man vergessen
also wenn es irgendwo probleme gibt noch
einmal muss man sich merken aber wir
haben zum beispiel die möglichkeit
geschaffen sofort kredite in der höhe
von 500.000 bis 800.000 euro zu vergeben
ohne dass es lange bonitätsprüfung gibt
ohne dass die banken zu hause haftung
übernehmen müssen
das sind kredite die typischerweise von
solchen kleinen unternehmen in anspruch
genommen werden also es gibt
hilfsangebote und ich glaube das ganz
bestimmt dass auch für diese reise
veranstalter etwas dabei ist haben sich
schon den nächsten urlaub gebucht
ja da bin ich das schlechte kandidat
weil ich seit ganz vielen jahren meinen
urlaub meistens zu hause auf balkonien
verbringen
ich bin ja als politiker und minister
gezwungenermaßen viel unterwegs im laufe
eines normalen jahres wenn es kein
corona gibt und irgendwann muss ich auch
mal in meinem garten die prävention
retten und die pflanzen gießen und das
geschieht dann meistens im urlaub vielen
dank für das gespräch herr altmaier ich
danke ihnen